[Inaudible] excuse me.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
this whole thing of Shakespeare's Macbeth men first.
So take that, um, take it could have been, uh
[inaudible] uh [inaudible] uh
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] um, via hung up there a lot.
[inaudible] come to see Steve Papa for the
Dean. Uh huh.
Oh, I'm going to show you here. So area, uh, family.
The school. Yeah. Okay. So
[inaudible] got bored to that rest in peace, man. Um,
[inaudible] have a lot on the soccer field, so.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] fantastic.
[inaudible] it was so fun.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] or if I go home
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and I'm in carriers. So I also have to bleed it also.
Well
[inaudible].
I believe talk there. They're all my name.
[inaudible] I thought they had [inaudible].
Dude. [inaudible].
Right.
[inaudible].
Oh, absolutely. Uh, you know, they come in [inaudible]
also.
Yeah.
[Inaudible] do you [inaudible].
Oh, however [inaudible] so, uh,
I wanna [inaudible] to, uh,
Autotrader auditorium [inaudible] [inaudible] make, um, also give some,
a cautioning. Baryshnikov is the lean dive.
Nick, Nick, I'm sorry.
The F and the old as a haymaker hula. I get
[inaudible] [inaudible] slim 10 bleak.
Two-state sewing and things [inaudible] or long drawn
by hand. This hand.
[Inaudible] action figure. [inaudible].
No,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Yeah.
[inaudible] that? I'm drunk, girl. God, I live on the extrovert.
[inaudible] there. They advantage.
[Inaudible] disability.
[inaudible] can
[inaudible] to accommodate and things from a very sound
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] at four C landlords.
There are so many Antonia DOR and valid Bleagh or
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Oh, lemon
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Layla someo. How are you? Uh, um, with the, uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] uh [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Perhaps no Christian post
my posts.
I saw it there program.
[Inaudible] 1980 100.
Yeah. Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] they make a [inaudible] leave there. Uh
[inaudible] did I catch them?
[inaudible] come up in the early scared mascara with the yoga or would not
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
He's already said
[inaudible] not ever. I thought [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
Uh, uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah. Sue
[inaudible] STIG. Matt King.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Ian Lynita intimate. Kamia compensated
[inaudible] first and then a man tall man, that
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Right? Yeah. You have to put an at the expected.
My [inaudible] and not some dog or not.
They leave your home and they will have fought. Uh
[inaudible] uh, or they are into the store. [inaudible] go
there. I sleep there if [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] yeah.
Stefan dude.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] they're going to [inaudible].
We do that. Reading to grow.
Your rings, the growth. Oh, today. Oh, you do some earrings.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] to represent your, a fair doorway count.
[inaudible] let me familiar. [inaudible].
Cool. [inaudible].
Oh, the [inaudible] don't
[inaudible] the vintage Yatra beta
[inaudible] [inaudible] to having it. [inaudible]
the highway [inaudible] film.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Hi, going in here predicted 15,000 to predict
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Had a gourd.
Foot. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Okay.
How do you [inaudible].
Oh,
[inaudible]
Oh, fantastic.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] he lives swollen.
Finsta. I'll just go see Anthony out in the we'll just submit
[inaudible].
Oh yeah. Can I talk? Not the desk though. I did some
Yeah.
Hm
[inaudible] for three or four
[inaudible] then you, luckily it's not.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] Steve popper.